[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
die mich aus münster kennen wissen zu
schätzen dass das in manchen zügen
reaktionär ist in manchen aber auch zu
analytisch in anderen zu historisch ist
von allem etwas worüber wir sich ärgern
kann
ich habe diese reihe hier so verstanden
dass man work in progress ausprobieren
da und dieses titelbild ließ sich so
wenn man hört pragmatischer
anthropologie dann denken die einen erst
mal was für ein überzogener riesen
entwurf die anderen denken was
historisch überholt und die dritten
werden am ende sagen was in einem
kläglichen zustand dieses ding was ich
in grundzügen vorstellen will immer noch
ist dafür steht dieses bild ist also
zumindest das letzte und vielleicht auch
die fragilität und baufälligkeit bewusst
und ich wünsche mir gute gründe warum
das ein gutes projekt ist zu hören und
ich bin auch offen für einwände die mich
dann dazu bringen zusagen an die
restauration dieses gemäldes geht man
sich besser nicht also ist wirklich work
in progress das zweite das liegt an dem
thema der reihe die glaube ich insgesamt
den versuch unternimmt philosophische
anthropologie und ethik in einen diskurs
zu bringen oder auch zu überlegen was
könnte eine zeitgemäße anthropologie für
die ethik austragen
positiv wie negativ und deswegen liegt
der akzent so wie er in dem vortrag
liegt ich werde also versuchen ihnen die
grundidee zu erläutern und dann ein
bisschen dazu sagen wo aus meiner sicht
die produktiven aber auch die
problematischen bezüge zur ethik aus
meiner sicht sind also die telcos die wo
wir uns gedanken machen müssen wo man
auch zu recht kritisch sein kann
es gibt aus meiner sicht
und ich habe das ganze angefangen
pragmatische anthropologie zu nennen als
ich mal gezwungen worden bin zu erklären
warum ich so viele verschiedene sachen
machen von außen und dann habe ich
festgestellt wie kann sie aufeinander
sinnvoll beziehen und das was man dann
ins zentrum stellen muss ist das was ich
heute erläutere ich habe auch
festgestellt dass es ein paar commitment
gibt ihnen das bild nicht reinpassen und
seitdem bin ich ziemlich rigide dabei
die zu eliminieren aus meinem
arbeitsplan
also das war hilfreich die eine seite zu
der ich heute nichts sagen möchte ist
sind die wurzeln in der klassischen
deutschen philosophie
das liegt an dem akzent auf die
gegenwärtige ethik diskussion
ich bin aber gerne bereit bei nachfragen
in der diskussion
wahrscheinlich dann zu lange zu dem
aspekt auch zu reden
es gibt drei säulen klassische deutsche
philosophie wobei ich den wittgenstein
eigentlich auch in diese tradition mit
rein nehmen würde
immerhin ist es ja auch schon erste
hälfte letztes jahrhundert also auch die
analytische philosophie kommt hier auf
dem kongress im bereich geschichte der
philosophie vor nicht nur die stones
haben jetzt schon ihre historische
dimension personale lebensform ist
gerade genannt worden das ist etwas was
mich systematisch interessiert das werde
ich gleich ein bisschen erläutern und
dann das was ich an stelle des mir
unsympathischen ausdrucks angewandte
philosophie oder angewandte ethik ethik
in anwendungen nenne das kann eine rein
kosmetische aber es kann auch eine
systematisch relevante unterscheidung
seien jetzt so vor und ich das
wichtigste was glaube ich heute ist ist
das zeitlimit damit für zeit zum
diskutieren haben dass ich kurz etwas
über die personale lebensform sage die
das ziel dessen ist mit dem die
pragmatische anthropologie befasst sein
soll
dann werde ich sagen was ich mit diesem
pragmatischen anthropologie label
verbinde
da das wort
anthropologie und philosophische
anthropologie eine bestimmte konnotation
hat vor allem ins großgeschrieben des
philosophisch ist kann man das so muss
man das in erster linie durch abgrenzung
machen das ist für einen grundriss erst
mal schön das ist ähnlich wie im
politischen befreiungsbewegung solange
man sich durch abgrenzung definiert ist
das geschäft halbwegs mehrheitsfähig und
nicht ganz so dornenreich um dann zu
sagen was das für die ethik
möglicherweise austrägt personale
lebensform ist für mich der versuch das
menschliche existieren anhand zweier
achsen zu begreifen die eine ist die
spannung zwischen einem leiblich
organismen und einem geistig
intentionalen leben die zweite achse ist
die zwischen einem individuellen zur
selbstbestimmung fähigen subjekt
einerseits das zugleich konstitutiv
sozial verfasstes andererseits also wie
bei mir beginnt die sozialität nicht
erst dann wenn autonome ich als freie
subjekte durch die natur wandern und
dummerweise ähnliche der gleichen art
finden um sich dann vor sie sich
umbringen in rechts verhältnissen
wechselseitig zu domestizieren sondern
die sozialität ist schon da bevor einer
von beiden auch nur auf die idee kommen
sich als autonomes handlung subjekt zu
begreifen
und das meine ich nicht nur
entwicklungspsychologisch das meine ich
begrifflich also das ist eines der
hegelschen erben in dem sinne würde ich
mich als sozialphilosoph begreifen
zugleich ist die personale lebensform
durch vorwärts gerichtet primär den
versuch autonomie zu leben und die
eigenen handlungen als
verantwortungsvolle verantwortliche zu
übernehmen gekennzeichnet
das macht auch die biografische
verfasstheit deutlich und ich habe
interveniert in die debatte um personale
identität schon lange dort für eine
arbeitsteilung plädiert dass nämlich die
frage der identität im sinne eines
biografischen selbstbewusstseins mit dem
person begriff als hermeneutik aus der
teilnehmer perspektive zu analysieren
das zu verstehen das phänomen zu
begreifen ist werden solche fragen wie
existenz beginn und existenz ende das
was uns zum beispiel in der medizinethik
beschäftigt werden wir fragen ab wann
ist es verhütung oder bis wann ab wann
beginnt abtreibung wann unter welchen
bedingungen tritt der tod eines menschen
ein dass wir dies an die mensch seite
des menschlichen lebens und dann
letztendlich auch nur unter kompetenter
hinzunahme naturwissenschaftlicher
medizinischer vielleicht auch
philosophie natur philosophischer
annahmen beantworten können
das ist also eine wenn man so will
operative dualität keine ontologische
das wird gerne mal missverstanden ja ich
kann mich da nachher auch noch mal gegen
wären das ist also eine mythologische
unterscheidung keine die in dem
klassischen bild zwar reduziere
substanzen oder so etwas endet und es
ist auch kein naturalismus in dem sinne
dass ich glaube dass man das wesen der
menschlichen person ahlen lebensform
vollständig in eine
naturwissenschaftlich egal wie
reichhaltige theorie über führen kann
es heißt nur dass es gewisse teilfragen
in dem gesamten setting gibt die man aus
zum teil ethischen gründen an bestimmte
disziplinen delegiert oder die man ohne
deren kompetenzen nicht beantworten kann
und das dritte aus dem praktischen neben
autonomie und verantwortung ist der
begriff der anerkennung das ist der
zweite glaube ich klarer bezug zu einer
bestimmten tradition
der steht dafür das personale identität
im sinne von einer biografischen
autonomen verfasstheit ein geltung
phänomen ist dass es nur innerhalb
sozial geteilter praxen geben kann
und das wesentlich durch soziale
interaktion auch inhaltlich definiert
wird das kann für bestimmte ganz
konkrete fragen zb die umsetzung von
patientenverfügungen für die frage wer
hat letztendlich dass die
verfügungsgewalt bei entscheidungen auch
über den eigenen körper
die deutungshoheit wer ist berechtigt
mitzusprechen das kann ganz konkrete
auswirkungen haben es ist also nicht nur
der alte metaphysische streit dessen
brasilianer meinten als
weiterentwicklung von kant etablieren zu
müssen das trägt auch was aus also das
ist so das grobe feld und wichtig für
mich ist eben dass das der eigentliche
fokus ist man kann auch sagen das alte
projekt hier ist eben nicht jetzt das
wesen des menschen zu expliziten sondern
zu verstehen was es heißt als endlicher
organismus einer bestimmten art ein
personales leben zu führen
ja das ist das kern bild und ich bin
dann irgendwann auf die idee gekommen
dass man dafür anthropologie durchaus
sagen sollte und vor allem in einer
tradition die vor der deutschen dem
deutschen sonderweg im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert schon längst begonnen hatte
das ist nämlich häufig aus dem
bewusstsein verschwunden
dass wir auch bei kant oder hegel bei
feuerwache oder maxi eine anthropologie
finden die also vor plessner gehlen oder
schiller liegt das verstehe ich unter
pragmatische anthropologie das eine ist
der bestandteil anthropologie den ich
ihnen jetzt kurz erläutern möchte
wenn man wie ich aus dieser deutschen
idealistischen tradition kommt
dann hat man es ja mit vernunft
begriffen und subjektivität begriffen zu
tun die relativ steil daherkommen können
also von der reinheit metaphorik die bei
kant und sichte da ist von dem starken
abriss muss der bei geldfragen
methodologische in anschlag gebracht
wird ist es ein weiter weg
die anderen aspekte des menschseins auch
in den blick zu bekommen und zwar nicht
nur als äußere limitation oder das
krumme holz aus dem wir versuchen müssen
unsere autonomie zu schnitzen sondern in
einer bestimmten weise philosophisch
stärker zu berücksichtigen und in den
begriffen leiblichkeit auch die tendenz
verletzlichkeit und bedürftigkeit drückt
sich etwas aus was für unsere lebensform
genau so charakteristisch ist wie die
fähigkeit zur rationalen oder sittlichen
selbstbestimmung es ist gleich
ursprünglich und gleichberechtigt und
ich glaube dass eine bestimmte tendenz
der aufklärungs philosophie da die dinge
doch sehr einseitig zum teil mit guten
gründen aber insgesamt doch sehr
einseitig akzentuiert hat so dass eben
denker gerade nach hegel marx oder
feuerwache nennen angefangen haben der
korrekturen vorzunehmen
und es ist natürlich eine
herausforderung der wir uns auf
verschiedene weise stellen können
ein ideal von autonomie zu verfolgen und
zugleich zu wissen als körperlich
leibliche wesen bedürfnisse zu haben
verletzlich zu sein und auch autonomie
nur durch unterstützung anderer
überhaupt realisieren oder später
aufrechterhalten zu können
und ich denke dass ein großer
unterschied wenn man sich zum beispiel
der pflege ethik oder aber dem was wir
in der public health debatte diskutieren
nährt ein großer unterschiedlich darin
ob ich die angewiesen haid auf die
solidarität anderer nur als beschränkung
meiner freiheit als notwendiges übel
weil es nicht anders geht begreife oder
als ein modus der realisierung meiner
eigenen menschlichen dimension ich
glaube das macht den großen unterschied
wie man sich diesem phänomen
philosophisch nähert ich glaube auch
dass eine philosophie die da die akzente
anders setzt eine ist die den menschen
die dann in diesen umständen leben
werden es leichter macht diese
lebensumstände auch anzunehmen und auch
die sinnhaftigkeit die darin liegen kann
sich selbst zuzurechnen und es eben
nicht nur als verlust zu erleben das ist
ein schwieriges thema und will nur die
tendenz andeuten warum ich glaube dass
wir in unserer gesellschaft diesen
fragen nachgehen müssen denn das große
elend und das ethische problem ist nicht
das was wir stammzellen an tun sondern
ist das was in den nicht luxus
pflegeheim überall in der republik
passiert und das ist wer sich da nicht
seine autonomie kaufen kann eine große
herausforderung für alle beteiligten und
da müssen wir als philosophen angebote
machen und mir ist nichts besseres
eingefallen als von anfang an in die
theoriebildung diese aspekte als gleich
ursprüngliche mit rein zu nehmen das
zweite was die philosophische
anthropologie eben auch hier aber schon
in einer polemischen überzeichnung
sozusagen betont hat ist eben dass der
mensch ein soziales wesen ist ja und
eben nicht der freerider der nur aus
angst und schrecken aus klugheit grünen
soziale gebilde aufbaut und das
autonomie zwar auch auf handlungen und
auch auf personen attribut werden kann
das aber das prädikat seinen genuinen
sinn auf vernünftig verfasste soziale
gebilde hat in erster linie sind
vernünftig verfasste gebilde in denen
normal sozialisierte entwickelt die
menschliche wesen sich bewegen das was
wir als realisierung von autonomie
begreifen sollten
und nicht einzelne heroische subjekte
die sich gegen die feindlichkeit der des
marktes der natur und der anderen
menschen in ihrer autarkie durchboxen
das halte ich für eine stufe des
verständnisses von autonomie und
deswegen ist auch der anerkennungs
factor etwas was in einem
wohlverstandenen sinne zu jeder analyse
von autonomie dazu gehört nicht in dem
sinne dass sich die autonomen
entscheidungen und handlungen anderer
personen anzuerkennen habe weil sie
sozusagen grundrechte markieren das ist
sicher auch ein aspekt sondern dass ich
mich selbst überhaupt nur als autonomes
subjekt begreifen kann weil ich sehe
dass andere mich aus diesem blickwinkel
interpretieren und mich an dieser
messlatte messen einige werden es wissen
das ist aus meiner sicht zentrale
einsicht die wir schon bei fichte finden
die dann aber gerade bei hegel auch als
grundstruktur von sozialen institutionen
und auch von verfahren in institutionen
ausgearbeitet wurde
nicht jede anerkennung ist eben die des
kampfes auge um auge sondern manche
anerkennung ist einfach die vernünftige
institutionelle geregelte ablauf von
verfahren die ich nicht mehr überprüfen
muss um eine minimal rechte
durchzusetzen sondern wo ich mit dem
vertrauen herein gehen kann dass der
geist dieses ganzen gerade der autonomie
dient ich weiß dass das romantisch
klingt ich komme auch aus einer
universitätsverwaltung und da ist es
möglicherweise an vielen stellen auch
problematisch trotzdem denke ich dass
eine normative sozialphilosophie daran
festhalten sollte das soziale
institution ein unverzichtbares element
der autonomen lebensführung sind und
nicht das andere der individuellen
autonomie und in diese konfrontation
begeben wir uns ja häufig ideologisch
bis hin zu den kolleginnen und kollegen
die dann in der inneren emigration die
autonomie der wissenschaft sehen und
nicht in der mitgestaltung von
situation ich halte das für ein reales
problem
und hier ist eine philosophische
anthropologie natürlich lehrreich auch
mir ist bewusst dass bei gehlen die
institution ali-t gegen die autonomie so
ausgespielt worden ist das ist politisch
reaktionär ist ich weiß habe ja gesagt
manches de was unter anthropologie
verhandelt wurde historisch und auch was
heute in manchen anderen disziplinen
verhandelt wird ist aus ethischer oder
sich der politischen philosophie höchst
kritikwürdig ich würde nur immer an den
kernideen als grund strategien
festhalten wollen ich bin nicht der
meinung dass es notwendigerweise so ist
das ein solches projekt autonomie zu
gunsten von institutionen oder
individuen zu gunsten von kollektiven
abwerten muss aber das ist natürlich
dann etwas was mich gleich bei der ethik
nochmal beschäftigt tempo realität
zeitlichkeit ich denke auch das kommt in
manchen heute sehr populären
moralphilosophie tätigen und politischen
theorien zu kurz es gibt natürlich ethik
typen in denen das quasi zum
ausgangspunkt gemacht worden ist aber
die erfreuen sich und zum teil auch
wegen mangelnder theoretischer qualität
nicht unbedingt größter beliebtheit
ich denke aber dass wir egal in welchem
theoretischen rahmenwerk das faktum der
endlichkeit der eigenen existenz der
endlichkeit der kontrollierbarkeit
unserer handlung der fall iby lied aller
unserer entscheidung und überzeugung
berücksichtigen müssen
in derart dessen wie wir begründungen
verlangen und auch anstreben
und vor allem müssen wir in jeder
hinsicht klar machen dass diese gebilde
sowohl das eigene leben wie auch soziale
institutionen fragil sind die sind
höchst störanfällig und nichts ist
geschenkt und man kann nicht genügend
als philosophen als philosoph sich immer
wieder klarmachen wie komplex und wie
ineinandergreifen bestimmte dinge sein
müssen damit etwas als hintergrund
gegeben ist in dem wir unsere autonomie
dann ausleben können also es ist im
grunde genommen manche würden sagen so
eine art störfall zentrierte diagnose
man sieht dann wenn etwas nicht mehr
funktioniert wie komplex die mechanismen
sind die ineinander greifen wenn wir
nicht sehen wie komplex die sind ja also
ich neige zum beispiel aus dem fußball
die besten spiele sind dann da wenn man
die hochgradige organisiertheit eines
mannschaftssport überhaupt nicht merkt
aber dass das hochgradig zu organisieren
ist merkt man an green teams wurde es
fehlt ja wo also fragmente versuchen
ineinander zu greifen
das funktioniert nie und ist glaube ich
auch in biographien so wenn also die
leiblichkeit und die geistlichkeit nicht
mehr ineinandergreifen von den kleinen
ticks bis hin zu den ausfällen demenzen
schlaganfällen dann merkt man in der
selbstverteidigung und auch in der
deutung solcher personen das jetzt auf
einmal dinge nicht mehr synchron sind
die wir immer in synchroner einheit
brauchen um etwas als eine person als
eine handlung als ein sprecher der ja
auch eine komplizierte verwobenheit von
bedeutung geltung schallwellen ist zu
begreifen und ich denke die
philosophische anthropologie wäre ein
angebot dieser komplexität nachzugehen
und nicht bei der idee von
formalisierung strikter begründbar kite
universalität anzufangen sondern in der
komplexität der strukturen erst mal zu
beginn
ich habe vorhin gesagt es gibt in
manchen linien der phänomenologie die
märz philosophisch nicht so nahe stehen
versuche dieser art und ich glaube
manche sollten wir uns da einfach an
eignen von der thematik her also dafür
steht das wort anthropologie
letztendlich steht dahinter die
überzeugung dass menschliche begriffe
werkzeuge zur bewältigung von
lebensaufgaben sind und wie alle
werkzeuge haben sie ihre kontexte ihre
reichweite und ihre grenzen und es gibt
bestimmte sorten von philosophie die so
tun als seien bedeutung oder geltung
historisch vielleicht sind mathematische
dinge so war ich will gar nicht sein
dass das gar nicht geht ich glaube aber
dass alle die dinge die für eine
philosophische expedition des
menschlichen lebens oder auch der ethik
gebraucht werden den index bezogen auf
die menschliche lebensform irgendwo
haben und den sichtbar zu machen
auch in seiner begrenztheit sichtbar zu
machen ist einer der dinge die mich
interessieren warum das wichtig ist kann
man eventuell in einer diskussion wenn
man mit trans humanisten redet die genau
versuchen diese kontexte ja
durchzustreichen kann man zumindest
spüren dass man jetzt darüber nachdenkt
was ist es denn da was jetzt auf einmal
verloren geht und ich bin auch der
meinung wenn man also von der rein
praktischen vernunft redet dass man dann
noch mal mir sagen müsste wovon
eigentlich gereinigt und wo die grenzen
zwischen einer sinnvollen säuberung und
einem waschzwang liegen und wenn das was
sozusagen völlig profitiert ist wieso
das damit uns noch was zu tun haben soll
wo wir noch nie in diesen sphären
spielen das ist eine frage die
methodisch vielleicht in die richtung
geht wie weit sollten wir idealisieren
und wo es für die praktische philosophie
idealisierung und kontextualisierung der
falsche weg
ja die die sich mit den theorien
beschäftigen werden wissen viel feind
viel ehr an dieser stelle denn das
gegenteil ist natürlich ja die ersten
will sagen relativismus ich glaube
relativismus ist die falsche diagnose
aber eine gewisse relational i tät und
gebundenheit und etwas was immer
kontingent ist technische fortschritte
zeigen
das ganz sinnfällig dass dinge die uns
fundamental ausmachen
zur diskussion und zur disposition
stehen können durch technische
fortschritte synthetische biologie ist
so ein beispiel
also ist ein sehr tief verankerte auch
von entwicklungspsychologen als eine
sehr frühe kognitive leistung erforschte
unterscheidung zwischen organismen und
artefakten das lernen wir intuitiv ganz
ganz früh
und wenn die synthetische biologie
fortschritte macht und gelingt dann ist
das vielleicht eine die viel weniger
kategorie a list als für 200.000 jahre
lang gedacht haben und dazu müssen wir
uns auch stellen
und wenn man diese dinge thematisiert
das ist auch klar oder auch so komme ich
gleich noch dass eine so verstandene
anthropologie sich auch mit der
kontingenz ihrer eigenen grundannahmen
beschäftigen muss während sie in einer
bestimmten tradition gerade sozusagen
als kontingents überwindung betrieben
worden ist na also in dem sinne ist das
eine alternative
das andere pragmatisch das kann man
einmal verbinden mit bestimmten
philosophischen positionen und ich
glaube dass karl marx recht hatte als er
sagte dass bei hegel das prinzip
letztendlich dass der arbeit oder der
handlung war und der tätigkeit und bei
fichte steht es ja schon als tathandlung
ganz oben in den systemen und so wie ich
das lese sind solche autoren wie fichte
schiller und hegel die ersten
pragmatischen in der tradition die ich
kenne
ich habe aber die erfahrung gemacht wenn
mittelalter experten im raum sind die
werden wir dann dann die mittelalter
personen nennen die das schon gemacht
haben und die er als antike forscher
kennen das auch ich deute das so es geht
gar nicht darum welches die ältere oder
die erste strömung ist sondern das ist
eine philosophische einsicht die
gewonnen und wieder verloren wird
sozusagen eine strategische entscheidung
von welchem phänomenen aus man versucht
philosophisch systematisch zu arbeiten
und ich verstehe unter pragmatisch eben
vom prinzip handlungen aus das ganze zu
organisieren und das bedeutet
letztendlich bei allen fans
in der analyse zu fragen wie ist das auf
menschliches handeln bezogen
welchen sitz hat dass er in unseren
handlungskonzept das ist für viele dinge
macht es einen unterschied ob man sich
der mathematik von handlungs ideen her
nähert oder von der wesens schau
abstrakter entität machten großen
unterschied wie die das betreiben nicht
dass ich da viel detailwissen hätte aber
auch wissenschaft obmann wissenschaft
und theorien als handlungs produkte und
handlungsstrategien begreift oder als
irgendeine andere art von entität
machten großen unterschied dafür wie man
es begreift es führt automatisch dazu
dass das philosophische primat auf dem
praxis aspekt liegt und das ziel des
praktischen ist nicht unbedingt das
wahre zu treffen im sinne einer von
unseren kontexten unabhängigen
sachverhalts bestimmungen sondern zweck
verwirklichung da kann wahrheit
sozusagen eine indienstnahme sein es
kann sogar kontexte geben rein
theoretische neugierde wo der einzige
zweck die wahrheitsfindung ist aber das
primat liegt quasi ja bei der aktive
schon verfasstheit menschlicher
subjektivität etwas was aus meiner sicht
die empirische tradition bis hin zu
ihren ethischen theoriebildung so nicht
hat da ist ein ganz tiefer unterschied
und eine pragmatische anthropologie die
eben diese ansprüche so formuliert kann
im grunde genommen nur als eine
orientierende und eine kritische
disziplin betrieben werden orientieren
dass sie zeigt was uns an bestimmten
fällen irritiert die aufzeigt welt
welche dinge jetzt aus dem gleichgewicht
geraten zum beispiel durch technische
veränderungen und uns erst mal klarmacht
was auf dem spiel steht
und ich glaube dass sie eben kritik sein
kann in dem sinne dass sie aufzeigt
welche verlust
wir und welche chancen wir bei welchen
handlungs maßnahmen maxime zu erwarten
haben was sie nicht sein kann
das hängt mit der zurücknahme der
geltungsanspruch und der vorsichtigen
handhabung von universalisierung
zusammen
sie kann nicht primär vor schreibende
funktion haben und es gibt in der
modernen moderne natürlich die idee dass
das wesen der modernen moral gerade ihr
vor schreibender gesetzes artiger
charakter ist obmann und für welche
zwecke man diese theorie ideal folgen
sollte darüber können wir diskutieren
ich glaube nur dass wir manches
anthropologisch pragmatismus macht man
die zeche erstmal zahlen muss und sagen
muss das grundgeschäft ist eher dass der
orientierung und der rat eine art
kritischen hermeneutik wer sich
praktischer philosophie mit dem anderen
ziel entweder der gut begründeten
vorschriften oder der gut begründeten
verweigerung von vorschriften anderer
lehrt wie viel wenig glücklich werden
das muss man schlicht einfach sagen ob
er mit dem anderen dann glücklicher wird
weiß ich nicht aber hier mit klarerweise
nicht
also das ist immer einer der punkte wenn
man so ein programm skizziert dann wird
gesagt ja das ist ja alles nett aber
mehr als ratgeber und einem gescheiten
beitrag kann die philosophie nicht
leisten wir werden keine harten normen
begründen können dann sage ich stimmt
aber anders kann man das auch nicht
ich glaube dann bin ich vielleicht
skeptisch in die leistungsfähigkeit
bestimmter form philosophischer ethik
das wird aber sicher haben wir gleich um
die ohren gehauen werden dafür ist auch
so deutlich gesagt ethik in anwendung
ganz kurz in anwendung ist in anlehnung
an eine von mir sehr geschätzte
formulierung des kollegen karl marx der
gesagt hat philosophie ist kritik im
handgemenge
es ist auch eine spitze gegen das label
angewandte philosophie oder angewandte
ethik diese metapher kann irreführend
sein weil sie nämlich so tut als hätte
man hier seine theorie ja und da die
welt und dann wendet man sich schön
darauf an und es ist klar wenn ich diese
hermeneutik beschreibe dann geht das hin
und her
das heißt in der anwendung werden mir
dinge klar und mit dem klar geworden
verständnis kann ich in die praxis
wieder eintauchen
da gibt es keinen fixen ausgangspunkt es
gibt im endeffekt auch kein sicheres
gelände alles kann mit guten gründen an
bestimmten stellen hinterfragt werden
aber und das ist gegen die skeptiker
gesagt nicht alles gleichzeitig die
universalen skepsis ist eine sinnlose
oder zumindest erst mal philosophisch
folgenlose position
ja man muss eben die motivierte kritik
an bestimmten dingen von der universal
kritik alles könnte falsch sein ganz
scharf unterscheiden
und dann kommt man zu dem bild das man
es immer in anwendung sich expliziten
kann so ließ sich auch diesen schönen
satz von hegel dass man nicht schwimmen
lernt bevor man ins wasser geht
das funktioniert nicht wirklich
das heißt für mich aber doppelt
kontextuell gebunden erstens das kann
philosophie nicht alleine machen
das ist für manche kolleginnen und
kollegen keine gute nachricht weil sie
gerne philosophie alleine betreiben
ich glaube dass wir ohne die daten der
lebenswissenschaften der so
gesellschaftstheorie nicht wirklich
genügend material haben um unsere fragen
sinnvoll verantwortbar zu beantworten
das ist sehr anstrengend
ja es ist schon mit philosophen zu
kooperieren ist schon anstrengend mit
kollegen anderer disziplinen sich zu
verständigen ist noch mal mehr
anstrengend und braucht zeit die wir
nicht kriegen weil er das dumme bild ist
interdisziplinär heißt fachexperten für
vier stunden an irgendeinem flughafen
zusammen bringen die schmeißen ihr
wissen zusammen
und dann haben meine interdisziplinäres
ergebnis und da ist natürlich der
unterschied zwischen einer summe die man
auch sammelband nennen kann und dem
wirklichen gemeinsamen verfassten text
den alle mitgeschrieben haben riesengroß
und letzteres braucht
zeit und ich glaube also solche
philosophie geht nicht ohne das
einlassen auf andere wissenschaften
da will ich jetzt gar nicht viel zu
sagen dass das viele probleme hat ist
klar
denn das ist nicht nur interdisziplinär
angelegt sondern auch transdisziplinär
das heißt wir müssen die fragen die uns
die gesellschaft stellt aufgreifen und
zumindest in meinem verständnis sollten
wir auch dinge so formulieren dass wir
sie an die gesellschaft wieder
adressieren können nicht alles also auch
wir haben grundlagenforschung aber ich
glaube das ist wichtig und da ist ein
problem das die gesellschaft natürlich
fragen nie so definiert wie wir sie in
der wissenschaft gebrauchen können die
geste so kann man aber nicht fragen kann
man ein zwei mal machen aber irgendwann
muss man dann versuchen die fragen so
zurecht zu legen dass die fragenden und
die geldgebenden sich noch darin
wiedererkennen und dass sie zugleich
operationalisieren werden in unseren
dingen auch das ist etwas wo glaube ich
nur die philosophen wirklich in der lage
sind die komplexität mal adäquat auch
mythologisch zu erfassen
das würde auch dazu gehören also eine
art meta philosophie dessen was man tut
wenn man inter und transdisziplinäre
unterwegs ist und die ethischen elemente
ich unterscheide
das sind nur die bausteine die ich jetzt
bereit stelle um nachher mich aus der
schlinge zu ziehen
die zwischen dem guten und dem
gelingenden leben begrifflich das
gelingende leben ist das was aus der
sicht eines autonomen subjektiven wesens
festlegt ja worin es seine werte und
sinn und ziele sieht das muss sich mit
einem guten leben aber nicht decken
das bedeutet das wort gutes leben heißt
es ist kein reiner subjektivismus das
ist eine korrektur funktion und
natürlich gibt es menschliches leben wo
autonomie überhaupt nicht vorliegt und
auch dafür brauchen wir
bewertungsmaßstäbe wie man die
zueinander bringt und was den vorrang
hat ja also ist dann so was wie die
grenzen der selbst
und in welchem namen oder wie kann man
autonomie in eine konzeption des guten
so einbauen ohne dass sie zum
subjektivismus wird das ist die andere
seite ist eine herausforderung
ich bin dann letztendlich mittlerweile
ziemlich sicher dass man dafür sowohl
das axioo logischer als auch das der
ornithologische begriffs instrumentarium
und begründung instrumentarium braucht
ist ja so ein alter streit ja wert oder
norman das ist gute oder das richtige
ich denke dass wir beides brauchen und
bin im moment weil das axioo logische
über die leiblichkeit und bedürftigkeit
mir verständlich zu machen und das
andere das der onkologische aus der
verfasstheit der praktischen vernunft
selber mit regel begriff und regel
folgen usw
ob man das zusammen kriegt oder nicht
weiß ich nicht ich glaube nur wenn man
eines der beiden opfert wird man in
vielen kontexten wo die angewandte ethik
gebraucht wird schiffbruch erleiden
das ist einfach ich glaube man muss es
schaffen um in diesem kontext und
plausible antworten zu bringen das
zusammenzubringen
ich habe es aufgegeben ohne beides oder
ohne eins von beiden auskommen zu wollen
und ich halte alle versuche eines der
beiden auf das andere zu reduzieren
für kaum durchführbar ohne dass ich
jetzt behaupten will dass das gar nicht
geht da sage ich einfach wenn einer es
geschafft hat lese ich gern und dann
lösche ich diese folie aber bis dahin
versuche ich das irgendwie kompatibel zu
machen
auch hier die ethik ist eben deswegen
ethik und moral eine orientierende
wissenschaft die angebote macht und die
sowohl gegenüber individuellen
handlungen als auch gegenüber
gesellschaftlichen entwicklung auch
kritisch ist also nicht nur es also
nicht unbedingt affirmativ ist sondern
sich auch ein nicht die aber nichts sagt
dass sie die gründungs leistungen
erbringen kann die in irgendeinem streng
wissenschaftlich objektiven sinne
verbindlichkeit haben
das mag in bestimmten gebieten ja sogar
gehen ich bin da offen wenn mir jemand
eine universalistische abgesicherte
begründung liefert die funktioniert
habe ich kein problem ich glaube nur wir
können und müssen sehr viele dinge auch
auf einem anderen level machen denn
viele der probleme sind sehr konkret
haben mit konkreten
entscheidungssituationen mit individuen
zu tun sind hochgradig kontextuell und
da eine philosophie zu haben die dann
sagt ja auf der ebene kann universelle
moralphilosophie des typs x1 nicht sagen
deswegen äußern wir uns dazu nicht das
ist ein kampf platz den ich nicht räumen
möchte denn ich weiß schon genau wer die
lehrstelle dann ausfüllen wird
und dann bin ich dafür dass wir es mit
schwächeren werkzeugen selber tun
deswegen arbeite ich auch in ethik
konzern ethikkommissionen einfach mit
aber nicht nach dem motto wie der ökonom
die ja immer alles objektiv beweisen
können bis man ihnen zeigt dass das auch
politisch motivierte ratschläge sind die
da streng wissenschaftlich modelliert
werden sondern mit dem wissen das ist
ein diskussionsangebot und letztendlich
sind es dann die politischen
entscheidungen die dinge treffen und ich
glaube dass das ziel auch der politik
letztendlich nicht ist die wahrheit zu
treffen sondern das lebbare und das
vernünftige zu ermitteln also das ist
dahinter und jetzt so wie der junge mann
ich glaube es ist ein junge da das sind
nicht alle toll ja bis in die
wahlentscheidung gegen den veggie day
gibt es eine sehr tief verankerte sorge
dass soetwas es letztendlich doch eine
bevormundung ist und dass dies sich
immer wenn es in philosophischen
debatten ist in zwei kanäle das eine ist
das stichwort essential ismus
schimpfwort es gibt ja so bestimmte
begriffe die in bestimmten community
street negativ oder strich positiv
besetzt sind wenn die fallen fängt das
denken nicht an sondern hört auf
essentiell ismus ist so etwas
dazu ist aber zu sagen man muss
verschiedene arten von essential ismus
unterscheiden
einer der übrig bleibt wenn man
sozusagen die konservativ aristoteles
für gefahr gebannt hat ist ein
wissenschaftlicher essentiell ist eine
weit verbreitete annahme dass die
naturwissenschaften letztendlich sagen
was das wesen der dinge ist ja so auch
in essential ismus und david friedrich
strauß schreibt 1872 dass wir uns
entschieden haben an die stelle der
theologie den glauben an die
naturwissenschaften zu setzen das war
aber nur ein anderes dogma das sei auch
nicht wirklich objektive oder näher an
der wahrheit
das sehe ich auch so
das bedeutet also essenziell ismus ist
möglicherweise mehrdeutig es gibt
varianten die ich unplausibel finde vor
allem aber ist essentiell ismus mit
kontingents kompatibel etwas kann für
eine lebensform konstitutiv sein und
trotzdem durch technische veränderungen
ja modifizierbar seien und ob wir dann
sagen dass sich die essenz geändert hat
oder ob wir dann sagen was dabei
rauskommt gehört nicht mehr unter diesem
begriff ist glaube ich keine
entscheidung die man a priori
begrifflich entscheiden kann da bin ich
mit hegel und auch dem späten
wittgensteiner das glaube ich ähnlich
gesehen hat der meinung da wird sich ein
neues sprachspiel etablieren und später
kann man rekonstruieren was da passiert
ist man kann als philosoph nur sagen
dass da etwas für die bisherige
lebensform ganz fundamental ist jetzt
zur debatte steht und dass es
konsequenzen haben wird wenn es nicht
mehr zur verfügung steht und ich glaube
die unterscheidung von artefakt und
organismus wäre so etwas wenn wir
techniken entwickeln die das unterlaufen
dann werden wir vieles in unserem
geliebten handlungs kontexten neu
beschreiben müssen und das wird viel
umorientierung bringen aber das wäre
eine objektiv im moment überhaupt nicht
erfassbare dimension also ich glaube
erstens dass eine gewisse art von
kontingents mit essential ismus
zusammengeht
und zweitens das ist wesen gibt und in
sich selbst interpretierende soziale
wesen sind solche dass das wesen von iks
auch eine historische dimension haben
kann das also erfahrung in der selbst
realisierung teil des wesens sein können
das ist also auch nicht eine historische
in varianz was ja das klassische bild
ist ja immer die historische universaler
abstrakte und theologie sierte struktur
die nicht zur verfügung steht meistens
dann auch noch normativ tabuisiert wird
das muss man mit essentielles muss nicht
meinen und ich glaube wenn man es
schwächer macht ist die alternative zum
essential ismus nur ein radikaler
subjektiver konstruktivismus und er ist
inkonsistent also ich glaube man kommt
um bestimmte annahmen mit modellen
stärken sowieso nicht herum weil unsere
sprache so funktioniert und das zweite
ist wenn die individuelle autonomie zum
wesen des menschlich existieren es
gehört dann ist ja in dem universellen
struktur beschreibung der platz für
individuelle lebensformen und
interpretation ja schon vorgesehen so
dass es überhaupt keinen notwendigen zug
gibt die das wesen des menschlichen
existenz gegen die autonome
selbstgestaltung zwingend auszuspielen
also begrifflich für unvereinbar zu
halten
deswegen eine unterscheidung gutes und
gelingendes leben die können auseinander
fallen aber sie sind nicht zwingend
inkompatibel und es käme viel darauf an
die konstellation zu identifizieren in
denen sie auseinander treten und dann zu
überlegen welche vorrang regeln für
welche fälle denn gelten soll
auch da glaube ich werden wir lernen
müssen und es ist schon viel gewonnen
wenn man die konflikte als dieser art
beschreiben darf und nicht diese
beschreibung einem schon um die ohren
fliegt als das ist unzulässigerweise
parallel ist weil man mit irgendwelchen
begriffen wie menschliche natur oder
bedürftigkeit des menschen ja dinge
einbaut die dem autonomie diskurs
hetero- nom sind damit schließt sich der
kreis main autonomie begriff soll diese
dinge als integrale elemente haben
das alleine öffnet die tür dies gibt
manchen dann schon zu weit
das ist aber das ist der preis und das
zweite ist haben wir in münster so
unsere debatten gehabt aber nicht nur
perfektionismus ist bei den einen ein
hurra wird und bei den anderen ein
vorwort
denn perfektionismus steht einmal für
die idee es gibt ein objektives ziel des
menschlichen lebens dass jedes
individuum anzustreben hat das ihm also
objektiv auferlegt ist und dass wenn es
nicht will durch erziehungs oder andere
programme auch dann eine
gerechtfertigter weise dahin gebracht
werden darf ich will nicht verhehlen
dass ich die gefahr die gesundheits und
bildungspolitik als moralische anstalt
zu betreiben auch sehe ja das ist aber
zwiespältig wichtiger ist mir es gibt
diesen starken perfektionismus und diese
konzeption von perfektion in der
philosophischen tradition
es gibt aber eine schwächere variante
ein kollege aus münster der ihr anwesen
das nennt das immer so eine verwaschene
sozialdemokratische minimal version der
ermöglichung 's bedingungen ja hinter
all diesen listen die wir finden so
unsystematisch wie sie sind bei luscombe
10 und andern die sind für eine fichte
jana als theoretiker und kunst
philosophisches system builder natürlich
ganz unbefriedigend darin zeigt sich
aber dass wir natürlich im groben und
ganzen schon wissen welche
rahmenbedingungen für die möglichkeit
autonome lebensführung zuträglich sind
und welche nicht und ich glaube zum
beispiel dass in der sozialphilosophie
oder im sozialrecht solche listen alles
sind was wir brauchen ja in anderen
gebieten möglicherweise nicht und das
heißt eine solche anthropologie sollte
sich mit dem begriff der ermöglichung
bedingungen und das fähigkeiten ansatzes
materiale anthropologische inhalte
erlauben ohne diesen strengen
perfektionismus als einer nicht zur
debatte stehenden ideal blaupause zu
verschreiben da ist konzeptueller
spielraum die debatte läuft aber eher so
entweder materiale inhalte oder formal
prozedurale moralphilosophie und ich
würde denken das ist letztendlich eine
falsche alternative
ob es und in welchen fällen was wieder
den vorrang hat kann man nicht allgemein
bestimmen das hängt von glaube ich von
den problemlagen auch
und das bild was dahinter steht ist eben
dem begriff der autonomie von diesem
idealisierten einheits konzeption zu
befreien und in seiner ganzen
endlichkeit aus zu buchstabieren dass er
für uns als menschliche wesen die wir
nun mal sind lebbar wird und das ist
noch mal ein motiv aus meiner
philosophischen sozialisation das ist
der punkt wo ich der hegelschen sollens
kritik und der hegelschen krank kritik
nach wie vor recht geber normative
standards in die welt zu setzen von
denen man weiß dass sie niemals erreicht
werden können von wesen die wir nun mal
sind ist weder heroisch noch klug es
führt einfach dazu dass die menschen
sich an den angeboten nicht orientieren
und ihr eigenes ding machen und da hätte
ich dann lieber ziele die aus
philosophischer sicht nicht ganz so rein
sind die nicht ganz so gut begründet
sind die auch nicht immer funktionieren
die vielleicht in manchen bereichen
inkonsistenzen erzeugen die aber so ein
attraktives bild abgeben dass man zur
diskussion stellen kann
und na ja es muss ja nicht jeden tag
spinat sein wie dieser junge zu recht
sagt aber ich glaube es sollte auch
nicht jeden tag schokolade sein und
irgendwo dazwischen muss eine
vernünftige philosophie mit augenmaß
sich austarieren und in einem gewissen
sinne ist das jetzt an team axis wir
müssen die extreme vermeiden in der
theoriebildung in der lösung strategie
und wir müssen uns damit abfinden das
ist jetzt eine ganz alte idee dass die
ethik vielleicht ein bereich ist weil er
vom handeln kommt der für theorie in
einem sehr starken sind einfach nicht
gemacht ist und dass wir das anerkennen
sollten und nicht immer eine theorie als
zweiter klasse als idealisierung
drüberziehen weil ich denke dass man
damit den herausforderungen nicht
gerecht wird das ist das programm
und ich glaube jetzt sind sie dran mir
zu zeigen warum es keine so richtig gute
idee ist ich danke ihnen erst mal für
ihre aufmerksamkeit